alors faut-il s'inquiéter de
l'apparition de nouveaux variants
faut-il fermer les frontières pour
éviter la propagation de cette souche
inédite de cordes un virus c'est la
question que l'on vous pose ce soir sur
le comté d g berthet france place au
décryptage
et pour en parler ce soir j'accueille
sur ce plateau va les rangs de
saint-just membre du bureau exécutif du
r'n bon soir va les rangers injuste à
vos côtés pour en débattre un vincent
chauvet maire modem d'autun et free
philippe froguel chercheur généticien
professeur également l imperial college
de londres philippe froguel vous le
spécialiste on en a beaucoup parlé
ensemble du du séquençage qu'est ce
qu'il a de si différent
ce variant qui vous fait si peur
est là une trentaine de mutations
différentes du
la chouchou original type de buran et
les parents très différentes et à un peu
un mythe
un initial et donc ces modifications
sont inquiétantes parce que
traîne résistance accent elles peuvent
entre une distance sévérité des
symptômes apparemment et ses symptômes
de lui sont peut-être pas si sévère que
ça entre paix sont différents des autres
est en tout cas ça entraîne une
contagiosité extrêmes on dit qu'elle est
simple pas plus importante que le delta
est ce qui voudrait dire que ça va
déferler sur le monde comme ça a déferlé
en une semaine on à l'afrique du sud
c'est un petit peu avec vous parce qu'on
a quand même bien besoin de comprendre
c'est pas vrai que c'est pas rassurant
ce que ce que vous nous dites
vous dites une grande grande
contagiosité mais c'est vrai que les
premiers cas examinés laisse à penser
qu'il ne serait pas si grave je lisais à
la présidente de l'association médicale
d'afrique du sud les symptômes étaient
différents le léger que ce traité
auparavant parlant des nouveaux patients
pas de perdre le goût ni d'odorat
ça veut dire quoi plus contagieux mais
pas nécessairement plus graves voire
peut-être moins graves
alors ce que nous nous attendons depuis
un an et demi c'est le variant qu' il
soit le virus qui soit très contagieux
mais qu'ils soient atténuées et c'est
comme ça que souvent les se termine les
épidémies c'est pas tellement parce que
les gens sont résistants c'est
simplement que le virus change et à la
fin devient très modérée et c'est ça
qu'on attend si c'est le cas c'est une
très bonne nouvelle parce que beaucoup
de gens sont affectés s'ils font pas la
maladie ça va arrêter la pandémie dans
deux mois et ça ça sera une très très
bonne nouvelle mais on n'en sait
strictement rien aujourd'hui la
population sud-africaine une population
jeune et qu'il faudra savoir c'est les
personnes de 60 ans passant de 10 ans à
qui contractent même vacciné ce variant
au micron est ce qu'ils sont malades et
ce qu'ils sont à l'hôpital et skimmer
qui sépare le cas très bonne nouvelle si
c'est pas si hélas il est aussi voire
plus dangereux que le delta bla on va là
par les ennuis il faudra probablement
faire encore une dose de vaccin est à
cette fois ci un vaccin modifié s'il y
une quinzaine de jours pour être fixés
sur la réelle dangerosité
de au micro au micro nom s'est passé
selon alors déjà on a du mal à les
nommer et puis je suis par ailleurs en
soyons honnête
donc qu'à une quinzaine de jours une
quinzaine de jours pour omicron micro on
sera d'abord ce qui se passe là bas en
afrique du sud et puis on sera avec leca
caen qui ont été importés en europe
donc on pourra répondre à la question
est ce que c'est vraiment un danger
majeur ou est-ce que c'est finalement
une chance le le virus atténué qu'on
attendait et donc on pourra prendre des
décisions importantes notamment par
rapport à la au développement ou pas
d'un nouveau avec là alors on va en
parler justement ces mesures avec nos
invités va les rendre un jeu vous voyez
réagir ce que nous disait notre
généticien philippe froguel or c'est
vrai que d'un côté ce soir joe biden
nous dit pas de panique et on ira aux
états unis dans quelques instants
le g 7 ans ils nous disent hautement
transmissible attention actions urgentes
s consisté reese trop facilement ou au
contraire il faut être précautionneux et
prendre les mesures tant qu'on a on a le
temps de le faire écouter ou moi je suis
un responsable politique je n'ai aucune
des qualités de de monsieur je ne sais
pas le le sujet de votre émission ce
soir c'est la dangerosité du virus mais
aussi la question des frontières et bien
posé le diagnostic
est tout à fait raison et il y à de
grandes craintes a peut s'avérer presque
la faim depuis début il ya quand même de
très grandes craintes alors supposons
que les craintes soit avérée qu'est ce
qu'on fait et c'était ça le sujet en ce
qui concerne les les frontières je peux
je pense lire le sujet est intéressant
politiquement je pense que nous ne
devons pas avoir de tabou et que s'il
faut fermer les frontières il nous faut
des fermes et et peut-être faut-il les
fermes et maintenant parce que vous avez
parlé d'un délai de 20 jours pour savoir
s'il était vraiment dangereux ou pas si
on attend 20 jours et qu'elle est
dangereux ce fichu il ya déjà des cas en
france et des cas en belgique des cas en
europe le responsable politique qui doit
prendre des décisions qui est au aux
affaires et qui doivent prendre des
décisions hamon change il devrait
vraiment penser aujourd'hui à fermer les
frontières et peut être très ferme et
intégrale lourds comme comme viennent de
faire israël ça représente énormément
d'inconvénients
c'est sûr pour les êtres humains pour
les voyageurs et surtout aussi pour la
circulation des marchandises pour
l'économie générale l'économie
européenne dans l'espèce et l'économie
française
et les impératifs de chanter à mon avis
doivent être prioritaires et s'il faut
le faire on le fera et voyez vous cette
question est en réalité très
intéressante sur le plan politique la
maîtrise par la france de ses frontières
on le voit l'art actuel avec la question
des migrants on le voit sur le plan
économique avec toutes les questions de
concurrence déloyale et là on le voit
sur les impératifs de santé les
frontières de l'union européenne ne
seront jamais fermé l'union européenne
demande comme le msd york l'a fait cet
après midi aux pays de ne pas fermer les
frontières jeune j'ai essayé de voir
pourquoi pourquoi par exemple oms
demande cela je n'ai pas compris n'ont
pas donné de raison est-ce que encore
une fois c'est idéologique en dix ans
mais la disparition des frontières c'est
définitif il faut pas revenir dessus et
qu'un pays comme la france ferme ses
frontières ça serait un retour en
arrière attention au retour en arrière
sur le plan idéologique c'est
épouvantable donc la question est en
même temps technique politique est
intéressant sur le plan du fond car je
pense que nous souffrons énormément en
france depuis longtemps de l'absence de
maîtrise de nos frontières comme nous
avons souffert dans le cadre de cette
épidémie de la déliquescence de l'union
européenne d'aider quel sens j'ai tapé
des balles je veux pas pu exprimer dans
un deuxième temps vincent chauvet
justement c'était intéressant de voir
alors qu'on ne sait pas encore la vraie
dangerosité on en a parlé avec philippe
froguel de de ce nouveau variant parce
que c'est à ce moment là qu'il faut
prendre les décisions politiques vous
seriez aux affaires qu'est-ce que vous
décideriez aujourd'hui est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec vale rente saint-just
tout simplement être radical fermer les
frontières comme d'autres l'ont fait
d'ailleurs en leur temps donald trump
avait très rapidement
fermé ses frontières notamment au
royaume uni
au début de l'épidémie que faut-il faire
dans ce genre de cas selon vous alors on
n'a pas dû lire le même communiqué avec
va les rendre st juste parce que l'om
est-ce demande justement de prendre des
actions radicales et rapide dès le g7
demande aussi à ses membres mais aussi
aux autres pays d'agir rapidement et on
voit qu'il y à déjà certains pays qui
ont réagi en limitant les transports par
radio parfois de manière très brutale
vous l'avez pour l'afrique du sud où des
avions en vol ont dû revenir de toute
façon ce qui est très clair au delà du
mythe de la frontière c'est qu'il va
falloir réduire les déplacements
visiblement il ya eu déjà une dizaine de
cas de aux microbes en france et donc eh
bien il faudra réduire les déplacements
par exemple les conseils municipaux vont
de nouveau se réunir en distanciait l'on
va essayer de ne pas forcément bouger il
ya un certain nombre de réunions qui
sont très fortement déconseillé au
niveau local les voeux les repas des
anciens probablement euros d'aidés
grandes difficultés à se tenir et puis
il ya des pays qui ont des déjà prévu
que on pourra pas empêcher les gens de
se voir pour noël les familles de se
réunir et par exemple le portugal a déjà
annoncé que après les fêtes de fin
d'année et bien il y aurait de nouveau
des mesures de confinement au portugal
donc ce qui est très clair c'est qu'il
faut limiter les déplacements les
déplacements par avion évidemment les
déplacements aussi entre régions et puis
même les déplacements hors de chez soi
pour pouvoir éviter de se retrouver de
se contaminer c'est absolument évident
et je pense que ces mesures vont arriver
bientôt en tout cas les préfets veb de
rétablir les portes du masque on a vu un
certain nombre d'annoncés déjà réalisés
et puis dernière chose c'est ce qu'a dit
le président bailly donne d'ailleurs
allé faire le booster allez faire la
troisième dose on voit que dans des pays
très peu vaccinés l'afrique de sûr c'est
30% on peut penser aussi à l'inde qui
est très inquiétante beaucoup de pays
aussi un damné moi je vais pas
multiplier tous les thèmes d'un coup on
va on va en parler pardonnez moi
oui allez faire intervenir parce qu'il
est il est vous vous avez une étiquette
politique vous êtes du modem est ce que
vous êtes hostile vous au principe que
la france puisse reprendre le contrôle
de ses frontières dans le cadre de cette
épidémie et de l'arrivée de ce virus moi
je suis un pragmatique c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui caractérise ou à moitié par toi
berthet et le pragmatique veut dire que
quand il y à des restrictions à prendre
et même des restrictions de deux dalles
et d'un département à l'autre d'un riche
d'une région à l'autre et pour bien
d'autres médias d'intérieur et moi
messieurs je vais donner quand même
aussi la parole à philippe froguel
d'abord je voudrais vous faire écouter
parce qu'a eu plusieurs réactions
politiques mais pas que on a posé la
question aux téléspectateurs je voudrais
d'abord vous faire écouter philippe
juvin lui qui se dit aussi pour la
fermeture des frontières
il faut une fermeture des frontières
pour gagner du temps face aux variants
omicron ce n'est pas parfait ça ne
marche pas à tous les coups c'est même
très poreux il faudrait un contrôle
extrêmement dur comme le font les
britanniques
qui est d'accord avec vous verrez rendre
saint-just on va voir quelques réactions
si telle est grave les virus n'ont pas
besoin de passeport profond sur les
frontières et circulent par tous les
moyens de transport du vin de
marchandises légaux et illégaux il est
donc de toute façon impossible
de supprimer tout transport entre les
pays c'est alain qui nous lie coco déjà
trop tard ça fait au moins déjà une
semaine que le variant sur le territoire
européen alors là je me tourne vers
philippe froguel un coco qui dit aussi
comme lors de la première souche les
citoyens devront payer de même
l'incompétence de certains philippe
ringuette évidemment pas de vous propose
vous prononcer sur des propositions
politiques mais qu'en pense le
généticien vous êtes est-ce que ça y est
c'est déjà trop tard pour vous
est-ce que c'est payé à long terme louis
c'est plié c'est à dire que le virus
omikron va remplacer le delta très très
probablement entre maintenant et la fin
janvier est-ce qu'on peut le retarder
oui on peut retarder en je ne sais pas
si on peut bloquer les frontières on
peut les contrôler et en france il
suffit d avoir voyagé est allé à roissy
ou orly pour savoir que et ça étonne
tout le monde d'ailleurs les contrôles
sont extrêmement
faible voire totalement absents et qu'on
n'a jamais réussi à mettre en place un
vrai contrôle aux frontières en tout cas
aérienne et quand ou dans les ports donc
ça on l'a jamais vraiment vraiment fait
en france et c'est dommage parce que la
façon dont ça c'est fait pour l'alpha
c'est à dire la langue là et puis
ensuite pour l'un dire le delta a
toujours été la même chose il ya eu des
passages
petit passage des gens cagoulés ont
différentes parties de la france et là
il ya eu des kloster temps qu'ils
étaient localisés s'est rien passé par
exemple pour le delta le 19 juin c'est
la première fois que nous on a trouvé
des invariants delta dans les autres
avant il y avait zéro mais à partir de
maman ça s'est généralisé ça a explosé
parce qu'il ya une congruence
ddd différents clusters et là ça a
explosé puisqu'à la mi juillet il était
plus que majoritaire le dell à ce que je
veux dire c'est que le contrôle des
frontières est un mois et bien avec les
masques avec
d'autres personnes
est un des moyens qui va permettre de
ralentir et pourquoi il faut ralentir
parce qu'on est en pleine cinquième
vague ce que disait le monsieur maire de
côté d'auxerre voilà excusez moi
c'est pas le micro c'est le delta
aujourd'hui en lutte contre le delta est
donc à chaque jour sa lutte aujourd'hui
en lutte contrôle delta qui augmente
tous les jours et ensuite on pourrait
aussi ralentir parce que le pire serait
d'avoir deux vagues en même temps à la
vague delta et puis la vague de l'eau
microns on ya entendu aussi le micro et
dangereux sinon ça serait une
bénédiction mais
avant de croire aux miracles vérifier sa
fête noël fallait rendre saint-just
c'est vrai que la russie a interdit les
vols en provenance d'afrique du sud
c'est pas les seuls à la suisse
également les états unis ferment leurs
frontières aux voyageurs en provenance
d'afrique mais ne ferme pas les
frontières on va aller à washington dans
quelques secondes
l'europe et de laxisme pour vous c'est
vrai qu'il ya il a raison à philippe
froguel et les contrôles n'ont jamais
été d'une rigueur absolue aux frontières
européennes alors que qui a voyagé c'est
que c'est souvent beaucoup plus sévères
quand on va ailleurs je retiens ce que
vous avez dit moi j'ai une tribune la
france pour la chance de contrôle dans
les aéroports il n'y a jamais eu de
volonté politique de faire vraiment des
contrôles à l'arrivée dans les grands
aéroports français et je pense que ça a
nui beaucoup à la population française
mais moi je c'est vrai que tout ça me
donne à penser et à parler du rôle de
deux de l'union européenne en réalité je
crois que si nous n'avons pas réussi
depuis le début de 2020 a résisté
vraiment à cette épidémie c'est le
résultat de ce que nous avons fait un
peu de notre pays depuis une
cinquantaine d'années notamment sa pose
la question de la désindustrialisation
de la france on l'a bien vu au début
nous n'avions plus aucun masque nous
n'avions plus de moyens de contrôle de
moyens de tests tous les médicaments
sont fabriqués hors de france nous ne
sommes nous avons vu que nous n'étions
pas du tout armé pour faire face
rapidement et efficacement à une telle
crise je laisse à poncer pour les autres
crises nous même pas sanitaire mais
éventuellement bactériologique extra qui
pourrait arriver et ça c'est le résultat
la politique industrielle
de du rôle de l'état de l'état stratège
de du territoire depuis des années des
années sous la pression de l'union
européenne
j'ai parlé des questions de migration
des questions économiques c'est un tout
et nous plaidons que pour un grand
nombre de sujets et notamment de façon
obligatoire on est obligé de le faire à
l'heure actuelle pour toutes les
questions sanitaires qui sont
primordiales pour nos compatriotes
primordiale elle est primordiale pour
moi les questions de santé évidemment
pour lancôme patriotes la france
reprenne au moins pour un trait long
laps de temps le contrôle de ses
frontières on va aller justement aux
états unis on va vous laisser la parole
évidemment vincent chauvet répondre mais
aller aux états unis qui était connu
pour être plutôt protectionnistes on a
vu donald trump fermer ses frontières
assez rapidement je le répète en ce
début d'épidémie
thomas bonnet vous êtes en direct de
washington notre correspondant sur place
comment a réagi joe biden elle avait 90
nouveaux variants menaçant
et bien dès qu'il ya eu une annonce de
l'émergence de ce variant omicron
l'administration de joe biden a décidé
d'interdire les voyageurs en provenance
de huit pays d'afrique australe l'idée
pour le locataire de la maison blanche
comme il l'a détail il ya quelques
instants c'est de gagner du temps parce
qu'il sait que tôt ou tard à ce variant
omikron sera présent sur le territoire
américain alors pour l'heure il n'y a
aucun cas officiel de ce variant sur le
territoire des etats-unis mais on sait
qu'il ya d'ores et déjà des cas qui ont
été détectés au canada par exemple alors
dans sa conférence aujourd'hui joe biden
a appelé à la retenue malgré le fait
qu'il y ait des inquiétudes autour de ce
variant il ne faut pas céder à la
panique écoutez le
ce variant est une source d'inquiétude
il n'y a pas de raison de paniquer nous
disposons du meilleur vaccin au monde
des meilleurs médicaments des meilleurs
scientifiques et nous en apprenons
chaque jour davantage nous combattrons
ce variant par des actions scientifiques
éclairé et avec rapidité et non dans le
chaos et la confusion spi 21 sièges
alors pour lutter contre l'émergence de
ce variant mais aussi contre le variant
delta joe biden a de nouveau appelé à la
vaccination il a également appelé les
américains à recourir à cette troisième
de cette dose de rappel pour tous les
américains de plus de 18 ans il a
également appelé la population à porter
le masque en intérieur dans la mesure du
possible il a expliqué qu'il n'y aurait
pas de nouvelles restrictions de voyages
ce qui fait d'ailleurs débat pourquoi
ces pays d'afrique australe sont
concernés par ces interdictions et pas
d'autres pays où des cas de ce variant
au micro-ondes était à détecter c'est la
question qui a été posée à la porte
parole de la maison blanche qui a eu du
mal à expliquer les raisons de cette
décision donc d'interdire les voyages
seulement pour ses pays d'afrique donc
de confinement à prévoir pour l'heure
selon les mots de joe biden qui
détaillera jeudi la politique contre le
commis 19 qu'il souhaite mettre en place
pour cette période hivernale il est
entouré on s'est toujours du docteur
anthony fauci chikhi ce dernier a
déclaré ce week-end et qu'il ne fallait
peut-être apprendre à vivre avec le
virus parce qu'il a émis quelques doutes
sur le fait qu'il soit possible
d'éradiquer de manière durable et
définitive ce virus ducobu 19 merci est
aux abonnés en direct de washington je
vais repasser par vincent chauvet
justement sur cette forme de
discrimination envers les pays africains
l'afrique australe afrique du sud vous
vous partagez ce la vie d'ailleurs de
l'onu qui
invite à ne pas isoler et punir ce pays
qui lui même d'ailleurs ce se trouve un
petit peu en position d'injustice
indique-t-il
c'est vrai que l'afrique du sud a été
relativement exemplaire dans l' alerte
qu'elle a lancée avec le séquençage de
ce nouveau variant qui vient peut-être
d'afrique du sud qui vient peut-être
d'ailleurs et se retrouve du coup un peu
mis à l'index mais c'est peut-être mieux
que la situation de départ où on sait
que la chine n'a pas forcément été
complètement transparente sur les
informations données ensuite les
responsabilités sont probablement
multiples mais si on regarde par exemple
la grande bretagne qui a convoqué cette
réunion du g7 elle a quitté l'union
européenne à peu près au moment du début
du coc vite ça ne l'a pas immunisé
contre les vagues épidémiques donc il
faut il faut voir aussi que le vaccin
français arrivent j'étais moi-même dans
l' usine sanofi en région parisienne qui
est en train de fabriquer le vaccin qui
servira de troisième dose que l'union
européenne est quand même un des
continents les plus vaccinée encore que
il faut regarder entre entre les pays le
risque je disais tout à l'heure des peut
vacciner c'est qu'on soit un incubateur
à rien six personnes est vaccinée le
virus se répand vite et puis on a ces
mutations ces variants espérons
d'ailleurs qu'on arrive rapidement à un
variant oméga la dernière lettre de
l'alphabet grec ce qui voudra dire
peut-être qu'il ya plus de mutation sera
ensuite possible mais sans plaisanter en
tout cas
l'important et j'essaie aujourd'hui ce
petit show band c'est d'avoir cette
troisième dose qu'ils puissent un peu
protégés et puis de ralentir la vague
parce qu'on le sait la difficulté c'est
la saturation des hôpitaux aujourd'hui
nos hôpitaux comme le disait le
professeur froguel il a raison commence
à être un peu rempli par le variant
delta si on 30 noeuds vague ensemble à
ce moment là ça va être très difficile
pour des personnels hospitaliers qui
sont déjà très éprouvé par deux ans est
quasiment de lutte contre l'épidémie et
donc il faut tout faire absolument tout
et sans aucune idéologie mais pas
vraiment l'avis des scientifiques et par
pragmatisme et suivre ce que dit le ms
c'est à dire et bien essayé de freiner
au maximum
ce variant outils philippe froguel on a
entendu donc oui comme le dit vincent
chauve et un job et d'un appel à la
vaccination enfin dites moi à ce que
cette vaccination ce vaccin ce qui est
vraiment efficace le sait-on contre le
fameux nouveau variant au micron omicron
on sait absolument pas tout ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que aujourd'hui on a une
cinquième vague de delta il est efficace
contre le delta et qu'il faut faire la
troisième dose parce que ceux qui ont
été vaccinés ya plus de six mois et bien
leur taux d'anticorps est en baisse donc
ça c'est le le danger immédiat ensuite
on peut imaginer mais c'est pas sûr que
si on a beaucoup d'anti corps même si le
micron entraîne une certaine résistance
et bien ça soit quand même efficace
puisque modern a dit par exemple qu'elle
augmentait la dose du delta du vaccin
actuel qui serait peut-être efficace
donc une question de dose ça paraît
absolument est logique ensuite on verra
aujourd'hui on est au jour le jour
simplement en france on est un peu en
retard par rapport aux autres sur le
dépistage du virus
je suis vraiment désolé de le dire
quand je dis ça en accuse de faire de la
propagande antigouvernementale mais je
remarque depuis un an et demi on n'a
fait aucun progrès il faut toujours un
mois en gros or à faire des diagnostics
de variants en france
le dépistage par pcr et à il a fallu un
mois et demi pour le mettre en place
contre le delta est là en angleterre
depuis aujourd'hui il est en place il ya
un test qui est en place et leur en
france le gouvernement est peut-être
parler demain pour dire ce qu'il faut
faire mais on est en retard d'ailleurs
vous le savez c'est pas ce que je dis
n'est pas discutable un partout en
europe on a des cas avérés et prouvés en
france on a des cas probables ou bien
qu'il ya quelque chose qui va pas dans
le dépistage consomment bien les gens
montrer piste mal et ça c'est la même
chose depuis 18 mois ou peut-être se
poser la question pourquoi on peut
casser comme ça va les rendre sûres
juste vous qui a tout du côté politique
c'est vrai que philippe froguel on la
vit depuis le début de cette épidémie
nous parle de séquençage qu'il fait très
bien à lille parce qu'il est aussi entre
l'université de londres comment ça se
fait qu'on fasse aucun problème au
progrès sur ce thème
jeux jeux enfin je veux pas jeter la
pierre du tout aux scientifiques
français et aux organisations
scientifiques mais je crois je pense que
la france est que l'union européenne se
sont mis dans ces questions qui sont
aussi des questions industrielles
scientifiques et industrielles
extrêmement en retard moi je voulais
dire une dernière chose si vous le
permettez on a parlé d' afrique et de
l'afrique australe à ya une information
qui va frapper moi aujourd'hui c'est que
la chine a décidé d'envoyer en afrique
un milliard de doses il est clair qu'il
faut absolument aider ces pays la note
sur beaucoup de plans mais aujourd'hui
la tuer je suis un peu étonné quand même
que ni la franche même de façon
symbolique ni l'union européenne de
phase 1 200 millions de doses quand même
en afrique par là
mua alors je sais que les chinois sont
très nombreux mais c'est pas ce n'est
pas le problème la chine est encore à
nouveau en train de prendre la tête
d'une dune d'une aide internationale
ils sont déjà très en afrique j'en fais
pas de de reproches mais encore une fois
nous il n'y a rien eu de structurel qui
était est mis en place pour aider ce
pays sous développés et notamment en
afrique enfin l'afrique du sud vous
pariez une population très jeune j'avais
raison puis les conditions d'habitat qui
peuvent être extrêmement difficile où le
virus peut se reprendre à toute vitesse
est très bien s'il n'y a pas eu de
volonté politique
dans cette direction là en fait un peu
moi je dis enfin je tue pas où tu pars
je n'ai pas aux manettes je sais que ça
doit être difficile je suis pas
scientifique non plus on a un peu
l'impression que c'est la politique du
chien crevé au fil de l'eau on voit
arriver des événements on n'a rien prévu
on est démuni et on nous fait un peu des
cautères sur les jambes de bois à chaque
fois et c'est comme ça qu'on n'arrive
pas en sortir ouais voilà vincent
chauvet le mot de la fin pour vous parce
qu'on arrive déjà à la fin effectivement
sur cette aide parce qu on a entendu
cette annonce will à la chine qui
envoient des millions de doses bon
kovacs en envoyer 201 millions louis
milliard deux cents millions alors on
sait que c'est pas toujours bien des
cheminées non plus faute de moyens sur
place votre opinion là dessus l'union
européenne a été un grand donateur de
deux doses notamment quand on s'est
convertie oprisor d'astrazeneca aussi
peut-être parce que les européens on
voulait un peu moins mais mais quand
même l'union européenne a été fer de
lance mais si dans ce débat pour sortir
sur une pointe politique peut-être on
voit le rassemblement national défendre
l'aide publique au développement pour
les pays d'afrique c'est bien c'est
peut-être bien toute chose malheur elle
a toujours fait on l'a toujours fait
merci en tout cas tous les toits
philippe froguel vincent chauvet va les
rendre sans juste merci d'avoir été avec
nous pour ce décryptage et face à face
un spa entre nous deux merci à vous